et le césar du meilleur espoir féminin
est attribué à
louane lra dans la famille ben ali un
jeune fille unique entendons dans une
famille de simon qui va se découvrir
grâce à vingt dix professeurs un talent
pour le chant
pour ce rôle eric lartigau rencontré
plus de 80 jeunes filles mais sans
succès car aucune de ces comédiennes ne
savait chanter contrairement à luan et
ce sont ses amis qui lui a conseillé de
regarder the voice et il a eu le coup de
foudre pour elle 2015 est une année qui
restera essentiel dans la carrière de
luan nra 100 premiers albums comme
chanteuse chambre 12 sortira en effet le
2 mars et est donc le premier césar de
cette soirée
je vais me poser ses concepteurs de luxe
et j'ai tellement tellement vraiment de
vin remercier déjà je voudrais dire je
suis tellement fier tellement tellement
fier d'avoir été nominé contre eux vous
les filles contre pas contre parce qu'au
final ce n'était pas vraiment une
compétition fort moi je n'ai pas
ressenti comme ça vous êtes tellement
talentueuse je voudrais vous dire merci
à vous aussi dit avoir voté pour moi et
et je vous promets que je vais tout
faire vous pas de vous décevoir
beaumont eric
je pourrais jamais jamais jamais assez
remercier et tu le sais vraiment merci
merci de m'avoir fait confiance
j'espère que c'était pas déçu et
j'espère que je vous ai pas déçu non
plus vous montriez de prod là bas
philippe eric stéphane karine france a
hérité aussi merci de m'avoir donner des
conseils et de macarthur et de ma voix
et doit voir supporter je sais pas où il
est lucas mon frère je t'aime et quatre
marques
catherine marque on m'a tout de suite
cru et je voudrais aussi bien sûr
remercier ma famille qui me soutient qui
me protège bah pas pas bon c'est bon